♪ (MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
So, it was felt Sandy, Stewie,
and Masbury Capital
wouldn't proceed with their bid
without you,
but they have gone public
with a bear hug.
-You could stop it.
-KENDALL ROY: Okay, yeah.
My dad wants me to do it.
Uh, I'll do it.
JESSE ARMSTRONG:
The first episode
of this second season,
it follows on like 36, 48 hours
after the events
of the first season.
And we were interested,
how does it feel to wake up
after what Kendall's
gone through?
What does his face look like,
what's his body look like?
What's he gonna say to people?
REPORTER: Now, Kendall,
tell us what happened.
Why did you get involved?
Why did you back out?
The long and the short
of it is, I... saw their plan.
And my dad's plan was better.
ARMSTRONG:
The interest of the show
is seeing these people
go through their stuff.
And they go through
quite a bit of stuff.
Ladies and gentlemen...
the first fucking thing my son's
ever done right in his life.
In the scene where...
Logan talks about
the future of the company...
LOGAN ROY: We need to discuss
this bear hug.
Stick, or sell?
ARMSTRONG: People will have
to decide whether they think
he is setting the table
for the discussion he has
with his kids
in a frank way.
Or if he's loading the dice.
Please,
I want you to speak freely.
(SIGHS) Anything you say
can and will be used against you
in a court of law? Like?
Come on, we're all pals here.
-SHIV ROY: Oh, yeah.
-Let's fucking have it out.
I fucking love money,
but I'm really scared of you.
-So...
-Mm.
ARMSTRONG:
Logan wants a family legacy.
When he looks at Roman, I don't
think he sees it there tomorrow.
And his son has
both betrayed him
and also been in circumstances
which make him seem
like not a good candidate
right now.
And Connor,
I think he would laugh about.
So Shiv feels like, "Well that's
what he's gonna do, right?"
It seemed obvious to us.
What I've decided
I'd like to do,
is to formally ask you
to come in...
and be the next chief executive
of this company.
It nearly made my cry seeing
Shiv sort of finally say
what she has always wanted.
I think there's some things
in life that you don't
almost even know you want
until you say it.
And then it can be
quite powerful and overwhelming,
the acceptance of it.
You wanna do it?
-Yes?
-(GIGGLING) Yes!
Fuck!
All right.
Yes.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪